two two two comics  two cigars two comics two cigars two  two comics two cigars that's the that's  a good title holy [ __ ] adapted  that's it well that's it two comics two  cigars a little bit it was to be about  the cigar yep and the rest is just  conversation yeah while we're smoking  said cigar one hour but two comments and  two cigars  here we are you could have any two  comics it doesn't have to be us doesn't  have to be us it can be it can be two  comedians half the time could be you and  i together the other half time could be  either me and somebody else you and  somebody else or two other people it's  an hour long it's however long it takes  you to smoke a cigar i love it  one comic is better than the other they  both think it's them and one comment  the one comic that's better than the  other is not that in shape but the other  one is